This probably seems like
a whole lot of magic.
How did Gradle know where
to find your sources?
And how did Gradle know what
compiler options to use?
Or what directory to
put your build outputs?
Gradle uses the philosophy of
convention over configuration, or
as I prefer to think about it, Gradle
has sensible, opinionated defaults.
You can lay out a Java project
however you please, but by default,
Gradle will assume your
sources in source, main, java.
And your test in source, test, java.
And your outputs in the build directory.
Gradle is married to that idea however,
and
you can easily tell gradle that
your sources live somewhere else.
There is a big upside to falling
into gradle defaults though.
It means you can pick up any
other Gradle Java project and
be pretty confident that you already
know how the project is laid out.
It also means that if the project
deviates from the defaults,
that configuration is
obvious in the build script.
Gradle also does its best to
separate capabilities from opinions.
The Java plugin actually first
applies the Java base plugin.
The Java base plugin is what provides
the ability to compile Java, and
adds the concept of source
sets to the project.
However it doesn't add any
source sets in particular.
The opinionated conventions
are applied by the Java plugin.